I would like to start off by saying
thank you very soon Sarandon not just
for the anointing in the words she has
just spoken but because she has been so
much in the lives of people who need the
human heart and the human spirit to be
in the midst of their struggle to better
themselves I'd like to thank Chris Rock
for bringing humor into the moment and
I'd like to also thank all of you who
were here this evening my very good
friends and very close friends who
turned out to be in support and all the
rest of you whom I don't know intimately
would have felt your presence in my life
because I've seen your art I've seen
your work I've seen your poetry and I've
been inspired by much so thank you for
all this and I will now get on with my
remarks for this evening America has
come a long way since Hollywood in 1915
gave the world the film Birth of a
Nation by all measure this cinematic
work was considered the greatest film
ever made the power of moving pictures
to impact on human behavior was never
more powerfully evidenced than when
after the release of this film American
citizens went on a murderous rampage
races were set one against the other
fire and violence erupted baseball bats
and billy clubs bashed heads blood
flowed in streets of our cities and
lives were lost
the film also gained the distinction of
being the first film ever screened at
the White House the then presiding
President Woodrow Wilson hopefully
praised at the film and with the power
of this presidential anointing validated
the film's brutality and its a grossly
distorted view of history this to
further inflamed the nation's racial
divide in 1935 at the age of eight
sitting in a Harlem theatre I watched in
awe and wonder incredible feats of a
white superhero Tarzan of the Apes
Tarzan was a sight to see this porcelain
Adonis this white liberator who could
speak no language swinging from tree to
tree saving Africa from the tragedy of
destruction by a black indigenous
population of inept ignorant void of any
skills population governed by ancient
superstitions with no heart for
Christian charity through this film the
virus of racial inferiority of never
wanting to be identified with anything
African swept into the psyche of its
youth full of service and for the years
that followed Hollywood brought abundant
opportunity
four black children in their Harlem
theaters to cheer Tarzan and Boo
Africans Native American our Indian
brothers and sisters fared no better and
at the moment
Arabs ain't looking so good but these
encounters set other things in motion it
was an early stimulus to the beginning
of my rebellion rebellion against
injustice and human distortion and hey
how fortunate for me that the performing
arts became the catalyst that fueled my
desire for social change in its pursuit
I came upon fellow artists like the
great actor and my hero singer humanist
Paul Rhoads painted Charles white dancer
Katherine Dunham historians superior
academic mind dr. W EBD boys social
strategist and educator Eleanor
Roosevelt writers Langston Hughes and
Maya Angelou and James Baldwin they all
inspired me they excited me deeply
influenced me and they were also my
moral compass
it was Rob's new said as you heard in
the film earlier artists are the
gatekeepers of truth they are
civilizations radical voice this robes
an environment
sounded like a desired place to be given
the opportunity to do all there
has never disappointed me for my life of
activism and a commitment to social
change the opposition has been fiercely
Bhutanese punitive some who have
controlled institutions of culture and
commentary have at times used their
power to not only distort truth but to
punish the truth seekers with
interventions like McCarthyism and the
blacklist Hollywood too has sadly played
its part in these tragic scenarios and
on occasion I have been one of its
targets however from the cultural
environment that gave us all these
social all the social drama all those
movies Birth of a Nation Tarzan of the
Apes Song of the South the name but a
few
today's cultural harvest yields a suite
of fruit Defiant ones Schindler's List
Brokeback Mountain 12 years of slave and
many more and all of this happening at
the dawning of technological creations
that will give artists boundless regions
of possibilities to give us deeper
insights into human existence how
fortunate for me that I have lived long
enough the Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences to have chosen to
bestow this honor upon me tonight is no
casual encounter for me along with the
trophy of Honor there's another layer
that gives this journey this kind of
wonderful Hollywood ending
to be rewarded by my peers for my work
and human rights civil rights for peace
well let me put it this way
it powerfully mutes the enemy's Thunder
approaching 88 years of age Oh truly
poetic that as I joyfully glow with my
fellow honorees we should have in our
midst as one of our celebrators a man
who did so much in his own life to
redirect the ship of racial hatred in
American culture
his efforts made the journey a bit
easier ladies and gentlemen I refer to
my friend my elderly friend Sidney
Poitier
[Applause]
problem
my boss now
I thank the Academy and its Board of
Governors for this honor for this
recognition I really wish I could be
around for the rest of this century to
see what Hollywood does with the rest of
the century maybe just maybe it could
these civilizations
GameChanger after all
Paul Rozin said artists are the radical
voice of civilization each and every one
of you in this room if your gifts and
your power and your skills could perhaps
change the way in which our global
humanity mistrusts itself perhaps we as
artists and as visionaries for what's
better in the human heart and the human
soul could influence citizens everywhere
in the world to see the better side of
who and what we are as a species I thank
each and every one of you for this honor
to my fellow honorees I could have had
no better company that have shared this
evening with each of you thank you
[Applause]